moms are allowed to be sexy we are
allowed to still have fun our lives are
not over because we have children
hey momma's happy Mother's Day to you
I'm Sophie she lacy senior reporter for
et online.com and first-time mom to be
and I'm gonna let you in on a little
secret I have no idea what I'm doing
today I'm taking advice from Amber Rose
and here's why she is an undeniable mom
boss Amber's a badass businesswoman with
a baby boy who never lets the mom
shamers get her down she is
unapologetically a hundred percent
herself and proud of it so amber how do
we conquer it all I mean like as society
teaches you you have to be a certain way
you know you're a mother you can't do
this you're a mother you can't be sexy
anymore you're a mother you know you're
not allowed to go and have fun anymore
and I truly don't believe that I want my
son to see me still do amazing things
and girl ups would be like man my mom
was having a good time she took care of
me she got up for school you know I just
believe that moms can do it all amber
and rapper Wiz Khalifa welcome to son
Sebastian in 2013 it's so funny cuz
you'll you know as a new mom you're
gonna read every book and you're gonna
be like I am gonna be the most amazing
mom ever and then your baby's gonna come
and you're gonna be like what do I do
now it's kind of just like you just
learn as you go but you've built a brand
on supporting women and supporting
women's sexuality and that's something
that I think a lot of moms can be shy
about I'm a true feminist in every
aspect so moms are allowed to be sexy we
are allowed to be sexual beings we are
allowed to still have fun we're allowed
to go out at night when our kids are
sleep and you know still have a good
time our lives are not over because we
have children you can't just sit in the
house and not have a life anymore
because you have children or because you
know your husband is away working it's
just it's not fair you only have one
life to live and you should live it to
the fullest amber says she's raising her
son to be creative whether that's making
music drawing or even painting his nails
earlier this year she went full mama
bear on social media slamming the haters
who trolled her five-year-old son for
loving Taylor Swift
thanks Taylor are you so excited
Candis mm-hmm she sent him a whole
package just like VIP tickets and
everything like that she's really
amazing he loved Taylor Swift he loves
Chicago he loves journey and it's just
you know it's just negative ignorant
people out there because it's like my
son is a black boy and for a black boy
to like a white female artist is either
gay or unheard of or what the hell are
you teaching him where's his father in
his life his father is very much in his
life
people just have all these negative
things to say instead of just being like
this is the sweetest most amazing little
boy and he likes what he likes and he
has amazing parents that allow him to be
who he wants to be tell me about kind of
putting him out in the public eye a lot
of celebrities do choose not to show
their children's faces I initially did
not want to really um but most when he
was around other people in our family
they would post him anyway after the
Taylor Swift thing I got on the phone
with his father and I'm like what should
we do should we you know take him back
off of social media and he was like he
was like no Sebastian makes people happy
let's just continue to just you know
keep showing how amazing he is and so
that's what we that's what we do could
you grow my belly talk to me about
co-parenting you seem to be in a really
good place well I think you have to get
to the point where it's not about me and
him right so it's not about like what
girl you have over there what guy you
have over there what would you know it's
like what is your schedule this is my
schedule let's figure out when you're
gonna see the baby and when I'm gonna
see the baby so we don't do like
weekends or this is my week or this is
his week you know we live very close to
each other and it's seamless
it's just in a weird way it's like we
became best friends after our divorce do
you have rules about when Sebastian is
allowed to meet people that you're
dating no no no we don't do that because
we
both know that we're both amazing
parents and we're never gonna have
someone around our child that is gonna
be harmful to him I want to talk about
being a boy mom
boys pee everywhere they literally pee
everywhere like you know he he loves to
run around naked he thinks it's
hilarious
oh he's rough though you know he's he's
rough and I kind of always felt like I
was gonna be a boy's mom yeah I just
always felt that but you know he's rough
he wants the rustle he wants the cake he
wants to fight but it's not it's just
it's just how boys are you know and when
I kick him right back we do do you want
to bring him in here and chefs now go
with them a little bit yeah come on in
hey you want to separate your mama mmm
it's your mama
oh I don't know if I get there he is hey
Sebastian do you want to tell me about
your mom a little bit what's your
favorite thing about your mama
I like wedgie I like when she goes to
work and then I couldn't come to you get
with us what do you want to be when you
grow up thank you for being here
all right all right go play watch the
wires honey don't trip